hey et it's my 16th birthday anna nicole
smith's daughter danny lynn burkhead is
putting the suite in sweet 16. marking
the milestone birthday with dad larry
burkhead who's getting major awesome dad
points for pulling off some epic
surprises
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah larry tells e.t danny lynn is
rocking into her 16th year with tickets
to a kiss concert but that's not all dad
went big and also got her a shiba inu
puppy named akira
she's my everything it's what i put my
daily energy my time my effort and i'm
just you know i'm so proud of the person
and the girl that she's become over on
instagram larry gave his baby girl a
special shout out alongside a collage of
family photos a heartfelt caption
reading in part quote through tragedy
turmoil and a couple of baby tantrums
today you shine bright and are so
accomplished so proud to be your dad
it's been a wild ride and danny lynn has
brought joy and laughter to my life she
always makes me smile laughing he ended
the message assuring danny lin that her
late mom anna nicole who died when danny
lynn was just five months old is looking
down
she reminds me so much of her mom and as
she gets older her features are changing
and i see so much of her mom in her and
[Music]
it's just like having like a little
miniature anna nicole running around you
know in so many ways but really 2022 has
been a full year of good times for the
birkheads
they visited amusement parks like
universal studios and got real fancy for
the kentucky derby
and the pair got together again to meet
music royalty
[Music]
yeah not only did danny lynn go to janet
jackson's concert she also got to meet
the icon backstage
[Music]
and how's this for a tribute the teen
wore the same exact outfit the singer
once wore almost 20 years ago we're
always on an adventure and while danny
lynn's no doubt inspired by janet she
told et in 2017 she wants to be a
different kind of artist
what do you want to do
you want to draw you're going to be an
artist
what i'm most proud of is just her
accomplishments and her achievements and
then when she comes home with
her report cards or
just little stuff like that you know you
just get this just makes you proud that
she's just doing great
[Music]
you